messieurs nous sommes dans votre café
tabac lors du déjeuner c'est un petit
peu le coup de feu j'aurais que vous me
disiez ce que vous servez le plus à vos
clients que mangent-ils vos clients
[Musique]
et avec quoi comme boisson de la bière
toujours et pensez-vous que ce soit bon
pour votre santé
sur du fromage pour un gâteau comme
maintenant et pensez-vous que ce soit
une bonne habitude oh non cette mauvaise
habitude mais quoi
salut stress ça change un peu pendant
pas tous les jours manger à la cantine
que mangez vous et comment vous
nourrissez-vous
on mange plus justement vous êtes un
petit peu corpulent est-ce que vous
suivez un régime
et la plage en maillot de bain vous y
pensez